ist das heftig absoluter wahnsinn ein
alarmstufe rot herrschen sondern wieder
sich auf spannende nachrichten für euch
und zwar leute ist das eingetreten was
wir alle eigentlich vermeiden wollten
leute die erdbeeren uns alle noch ganz
gut an zwei videos die vor einigen tagen
bei youtube kanal angegangen sind da
ging es letztlich um die hilfe folge
essen macht mich gl wird ein junge
namens last davon gab es zwei folgen ich
habe auch weiter reagiert und wir
dachten eigentlich
wir dachten eigentlich dass wir dieses
kapitel dieses dunkle kapitel zu
verstanden haben wir nicht mist ich
nehme dieses video hier am 19 april um
16 46 auf 45 minuten ist teil 3 von
dieser serie und angekommen leute haltet
euch fest schnallt euch in einem stuhl
an wir schauen jetzt rein ja so leute
das ist durch die story also die die
story von dieser folge ist dass lars
endlich seine essens sucht überwunden
hat war seine wieder soll man sagen ja
das ist politisierung von essen dass er
darüber drüber hinweg ist also stellen
aber schreiben eine therapie gemacht hat
dass er mit seiner freundin mit den
angry birds augenbrauen zusammen gezogen
ist und das eigentlich sein leben auf
dem richtigen weg war
das ist natürlich eine story leute sehen
uns einig da kann hilft mir nichts mit
anfangen
deswegen raten wieder voll rein
wieder nix das ekt müssen wieder das
wieder und prüfen muss man sagen diese
verzweiflung die emotionale verzweifeln
wie man wirklich aus der stimme raus
spürt ich würde handapparat mist mein
leben ist so schlecht gerade so richtig
mpc dialog beziehen
[Musik]
du bist du
wir dachten wir dachten wirklich wir
hätten zu verbunden leitete haben ist
nicht überwunden es geht wieder los
übrigens auch meinen anmachspruch immer
im kopf das ist ackermann strategie wenn
ich feiern gut jetzt gerade kommt
natürlich fein geht aber wenn ich sonst
mal im club unterwegs mit oder mal
draußen feiern bin und ich sehe eine
nette junge dame wäre hier ist meine
strategie auch immer zu ihr hin zu gehen
und sie mit den worten anzusprechen
danach hätte ich mal ein bisschen über
die geil ist wie sie hat und dann läuft
das eigentlich
nein auf keinen fall
du kannst es nicht erkannt dass ich
leute also ja welche sendung schauen wer
hatte schauen wir gerade das was ich aus
weg aus den schulden oder schauen wir
hilf mir junge hör mir jetzt mal gut zu
ok lass den kuchen stehen ist ein kuchen
care ist es süßes gebäck mit einer
zugegebenermaßen ok bin ich bei dir
relativ meisten sagen creme obendrauf so
aber das ist kein objekt
das ärgert mich jetzt wirklich da kannst
du nicht nur den kuchen ganz lassen
du hast den komplett verhunzt alter
spiele auf sand wasser sei so gut lass
bitte dein t-shirt an ok ich weiß ist es
schwer weil weißt du hast auch recht
schicken bierbauch da denen wir uns
gerne präsentieren will
aber ich würde dir raten ihnen davon
doch gerne abstand
in die richtung brauchen wir gar nicht
weiter gehen leute das haben wir schon
zwei folgen lang gehabt das brauchen wir
nicht mehr lenken wir uns noch kurz mal
von diesem thema ab leute und
fokussieren uns auf eine andere sehr
wichtige frage die wir uns alle bei
dieser hilfe folge stellen wird es hilft
mir dieses mal schaffen den green screen
richtig einzusetzen
werden sie es schaffen dass das bild
beim green screen nicht grün ist sondern
tatsächlich der green screen genutzt
wird
[Musik]
dicker nie die linie des dfb ich wollte
eigentlich weiter zu springen bis zum
grün aber ich habe das einfach mal
durchlaufen schlechte idee dass triggert
so hart alter die dieser schöne kuchen
das ist so als hättest feiern wird ob
das ist absolut gegenteil von zska zum
perfekten kuchen
ja und dann so ein hessler und der damit
seinen händen drin um grip was hat sie
zu viel
das heißt er hat eine vorliebe für
lebensmittel
offenbar hat lars diese neigung trotz
therapie noch nicht in den griff
bekommen
das stimmt eigentlich nicht mehr jetzt
jetzt wo ich sag es mir auch aufgefallen
ich glaube ich konnte gerade nicht zu
meinen finger drauf wurden was es ist
jetzt kann ich glaube das hat sein leben
nicht im griff
seht ihr es jetzt auch leute jetzt wo
sie es gesagt hat können wir kann ich
glaube ich jetzt kann ich erkennen -
immer hinten und man muss sagen wollte
kleine applaus greenscreen funktioniert
das bei
was machst du hier was was ist das was
machst du da ist es etwa die torte und
button heran
stellen sie sich einmal vor kommt nach
hause und ihr lauft in dieses szenario
rein was für ein trauerspiel kann ein
menschliches leben sein
ich habe jetzt ich finde so abgelenkt
worden davon ich konnte ich mal ihre
augenbrauen achten ist sie noch auf
einen reverse modus ja dass das so weit
noch alles im rahmen leute dass noch
alles okay für alle die den job ich
mitbekommen haben hier nochmal das
augenbrauen vergleichsbild daher kommt
die inspiration nein das ist ja es ist
eine torte das ist ohne frage hat das
sieht man doch kranke situation alter
ich wollte mir nur die torte aus dem
kühlschrank holen und ich mich versehen
habe habe ich auf einmal kein t shirt
man keine hosen an und die torte ist in
der ganzen kirche verteilt leute es ist
wirklich gefährlich augen auch beim
kühlschrank kaufen
ich dachte du aussiehst ja sagt mir die
wahrheit bist du wieder rückfällig
geworden steht daneben
lars last bitte du musst mir die
wahrheit sagen weil ich kann anhand der
jetzigen aktuellen situationen die sich
jetzt mir meine augen gerade da bietet
nicht erkennen ob du rückfällig geworden
bin
das kann es etwa sein also ich glaube
heute die faktenlage ist noch nicht
eindeutig sie soll noch ein bisschen
weiter recherchieren
garantiert nicht ich hab mir meine nein
er liegt nicht
er liebt entdecker sina sina heißt die
single halo wieso sollte der lügen gegen
gibt es irgendwelche anhaltspunkte dafür
dass er wieder rückfällig geworden ist
in seiner anziehung für lebensmittel
sehen wir hier gerade irgendwelche
anhaltspunkte leute jedweder art mehr
oder auch wenn das ein rückfall peinlich
ist er sollte sich seiner freundin sina
anvertrauen und ehrlich zu ihr sein
nur so kann sich seinen problemen
stellen und gemeinsam mit ihr nach einer
lösung suchen
dazu kommt auch noch dass man sina
erzählen könnte wenn man mit ihr vor die
tür geht und man schaut in den himmel
und der himmel ist blau
ok himmel ist blau keine einzige wolke
dann könnte man sina tatsächlich
erzählen der himmel ist lila und sie
würde es einem glauben ich weiß sie ist
ist sina blind
wir können uns doch ausmachen wie dass
es wieder aus der garage okay also es
für seiner mutter seine mutter hat ihn
abgeduscht hat ihn quasi wieder
aufgenommen nachdem seine frau ihn
rausgeschmissen hat was macht sie als
erstes gibt ihm erst mal unbeaufsichtigt
essen das ist wirklich liebe mutter von
lars einer der dümmsten ideen die ich
jemals gehört habe
die sieht auch aus wie hund
ich weiß wenn das normale erbsensuppe
ist meine mutter immer ziemlich gute
erbsensuppe gemacht
ja das ist dieses jahr schrecklich aus
das hat auf dich
absoluter wahnsinn
nein nein nein nein leute leute künstler
ausgang ist der weg den ich jetzt wählen
werde um mich aus dieser situation zu
erlösen
ich muss ganz ehrlich gestehen wir für
mich um damit von diesem video geschafft
acht minuten 30 von 18 minuten weiter
habe ich nicht okay leute jetzt war für
alle die sonst mit werden wenn ich nicht
zumindest die ganze folge mal durch es
gibt hätte er kriegt dann in diesem
komischen lager job oder so in den
supermarkt und haut sich da dann
irgendwelche schlüsse rein den spruch
hätte ich in einem anderen kontext
eingesetzt und dann ganz am ende des
videos wahrscheinlicher so getan als
wäre er geheilt und wunder leute wir
sind wirklich schockiert die welt ist
schockiert er wird wieder rückfällig und
zwar in dieser art und weise leute rein
mit euch knackigen dingern das ist heute
wirklich dass das wort zum sonntag an
der stelle
da habe ich mich endgültig verabschiedet
ich nehme jetzt den konten oder ausgang
leute hier darüber gibt es einfach ich
vorher kleines video rein mit dem kann
gegen den trend mit einem knackigen ab
wieder menschen nicht gesehen ziemlich
abstoßend